hallo
herzlich willkommen in meiner torten
welt heute gibt's bei mir mal wieder
nichts süßes sondern etwa falls es zum
essen und zwar arbeite ich heute komme
es machen aber nicht aus kartoffeln
sondern aus süßkartoffeln die
süßkartoffel kennen vielleicht einige
von euch aus dem supermarkt die gibt es
in mehreren farben das hier ist eine
rote süßkartoffel und was ich selbst
nicht wusste um die zwei recherchiert
herausgefunden habe ist das eine
süßkartoffel gar keine kartoffel ist
also die hat nix mit unseren kartoffeln
zu tun die wir hier in deutschland eben
auf anbauen
das nämlich botanisch gesehen zwei ganz
unterschiedliche sorten und zwar sind
unsere ganz normalen kartoffeln die wir
so als pommes zubereitet sind
nachtschattengewächse und diese
süßkartoffeln sind zwar auch genommen
die unter der erde wachsen
aber das sind windeln gewechselt und den
somit gar nicht mit unserer kartoffel
verband die heißen einfach nur so ein
ganz großer unterschied bei den zwei
gewechselt ist dass man bei diesen
normalen kartoffeln nur die kartoffel
essen kann also das was unter der erde
wächst und das was drüber weg sich als
giftig soll mal ehrlich essen aber bei
der süßkartoffel sind die blätter
oberhalb der erde auch zum verzehr
geeignet die werden dann einfach so
spinat ihn nicht so bereitet und sind
anscheinend ein richtiger genuss ich
auch nicht gegessen möchte auf jeden
fall auch mal ausprobieren ich möchte
heute süßkartoffel commons aus dem ofen
machen und werde ich das jetzt auch
gleich zeigen und anschließend werde ich
euch noch ein paar gründe nennen wieso
man süßkartoffeln essen sollte und
verzehren sollte die süßkartoffeln sind
nämlich richtig gesund und wegen sich
wirklich ganz gut auf eure gesundheit
aus ich habe dir ein paar süßkartoffeln
ich werde die ungeschälten lassen ich
habe sie jetzt schön abgewaschen mit
seinem kleineren schwamm und wer sie
jetzt in kleine stücke schneiden
zwar möchte ich jetzt richtig schöne
lange pommes und setzte dafür etwa 12
zentimeter breite preis stückchen
schneiden
und dann gebe ich sehr einfach auch mal
nach vorheriger auf einem backblech und
da teufel ich jetzt ein bisschen
olivenöl drüber und fand es schön und
dann kommen die kartoffeln in den
vorgeheizten ofen
ich habe jetzt ober und unterhitze etwa
200 grad eingestellt
ihr könnt auch das 22 gehen aber auf
jeden fall müsste aufpassen dass euch
die süßkartoffel nicht verbrennen
die sind nämlich schneller als normale
kartoffeln also ich schätze mal so 40
minuten es könnte doch auch nur 30
werden das zeige ich euch jetzt gleich
und ihr dürft natürlich die kartoffeln
auch gerne etwas würzen ich werde später
allerdings nur mit etwas salz gestreut
das mache aber nach dem backen auch weil
es gerne mag kann hier eben mittels öl
noch wiesenknopf aufgeben oder paprika
curry je nachdem was ihr eben mögt und
in der zwischenzeit gebe ich euch jetzt
noch einige informationen rund um die
süßkartoffel und zwar habe ich diese
informationen von der internetseite
zentrum der gesundheit und da steht zum
beispiel auch dass man die süßkartoffel
auch ganz gut essen kann
diesmal hat und schon gegessen
von der konsistenz herren ist so wie so
eine mischung aus karotte und erdapfel
so leicht trocken aber richtig schön
dass süßlicher geschmack und wirklich
sehr lecker und von dieser internetseite
habe ich jetzt zehn gründe weshalb man
süßkartoffeln essen sollte möchte ich
euch jetzt ganz kurz mal vorstellen und
1 die süßkartoffel ist ungewöhnlich
reich an antioxidantien
das heißt im körper des tv borken gegen
entzündungen und eben auch krankheiten
die auf so entzündungen basiert wie zb
asthma arthritis gicht und ganz viele
andere krankheiten der kunde nummer zwei
ist dass die süßkartoffel eine
exzellente
für kohlenhydrate ist und deswegen wirkt
sie blutspiegel regulieren
das heißt menschen die probleme mit dem
blutzuckerspiegel haben müssen ganz
viele süßkartoffel essen damit nämlich
ganz schön reguliert konnten mal drei
süßkartoffeln sind ballaststoffreich für
alle dinge wenn sie meter schale
gegessen werden
ich stehe sowieso mein obst und gemüse
recht ungern weil ich weiß dass die
vitamine und mineralstoffe da eben drin
sitzen in dieser schale und zwar echt
schade wenn man die e wegschmeißt
deswegen es süßkartoffeln wieder schaden
sie ist der werkstoff preis das heißt
sie wirklich nur verstopfung entgegen
sondern wollte eben auch darmkrebs vor
grund nummer 4 ist also günstig ist und
für schwangere frauen ein kinderwunsch
haben und kleinkinder weil sie ganz viel
vollath enthalten das ist natürlich ein
vor säure und das hilft gerade kleinen
kindern über mädchen und schwangeren
eben ganz gut zur entwicklung und trägt
dazu bei
und deswegen solltet ihr das ganz
besonders viel essen und nummer fünf
die süßkartoffel steckt eure abwehrkraft
und zwar enthält die süßkartoffel ganz
viele sekundäre pflanzenstoffe die eure
immunabwehr richtig doll stärkt und
nummer sechs die süßkartoffel hilft
euren herz und zwar hat enthält sie ganz
viel kalium und dieses kalium kann die
herzinfarkte und schlaganfälle präventiv
bekämpfen und außerdem stabilisiert sie
den blutdruck was ich eben auch gut auf
das herz auswirkt konnte sieben ist dass
die süßkartoffel die muskelkrämpfe
vermeiden kann muss ich grenze kommen
dadurch zustande dass man ein
magnesiummangel hat aber es liegt eben
nicht nur an dem magneten mangel sondern
auch an kalium an
und da diese stoffe reich an kalium ist
könnt ihr dadurch eben muskelkrämpfe
vorbeugend kundennummer acht die
süßkartoffel ist ein stresskiller das
heißt menschen die sehr häufig zu stress
leiden sondern auch süßkartoffel essen
weil die nämlich ganz viele
mineralstoffe enthält die eben diese
stress gezogenen symptome bekämpft und
dadurch könnte eben euer mineralhaushalt
wieder auf vordermann bringen und zeit
für die nächste stresssituation gut
gewappnet nummer 9
die süßkartoffel potter als gesundes
gemüse überhaupt ausgezeichnet und 26
kartoffel reich an nährstoffen und an
vitalstoffen und wurde daher wirklich zu
platz eins des gesunden gemüses gewählt
auf platz zwei steht übrigens die
kartoffel und zwar die süße dort 984
punkte bekommen und die kartoffel die
auf platz zwei stehen und 83 punkte also
schon ein deutlicher unterschied und
dann zu meinem zehnten und letzten punkt
im die süßkartoffel kann man ganz gut
essen
das ist wirklich eine richtig gute und
leckere rohkost und dadurch enthält sie
ihre ganzen vitamine gehen keine
vitamine kaputt weil er sie nicht
erhitzen ist und die süßkartoffel soeben
wirklich sehr gut schmeckt kann ich mir
ganz gut vorstellen mit seinem schönen
tipp also praktisch das gleiche wie
jetzt bei mir im ofen ist innovation mit
steht die kartoffeln sind gar wenn er
mit der gabel rein steckt und sie schön
weich sind
ihr könnt ihr natürlich auch länger drin
lassen dann werden sie etwas knuspriger
aber ich mag es jetzt ganz gerne so hier
habe ich übrigens ein paar süßkartoffeln
in ganz dünne scheiben gehobelt möchte
ich gleich noch chips draus machen und
jetzt nehme ich einfach etwas salz und
zahlte die kartoffeln damit wie gesagt
könnte das auch schon vor dem backen
machen setzt sich einfach auch nicht
schön
so sieht das ganze dann aus und ich gebe
da noch etwas screen mit dazu das rezept
für meinen film kennt ihr bereits das
verlinkte ich euch einfach hier oben und
natürlich auch in der infobox und wenn
ihr gerne mehr rezepte hamborn einfache
gesunde rezepte dann lass mir ein
kommentar
und auch ob euch diese kleine warenkunde
gefallen hat dann braucht es nämlich
hinten mal wieder in meine videos mit
ein
ich hoffe dass euch dieses rezept
gefällt ich werde jetzt gleich noch mal
die chips ausprobieren falls ihr dazu
auch im video haben möchtet das
ebenfalls einen kommentar dran
auf jeden fall solltet ihr noch wissen
dass dieses kartoffeln so etwa innerhalb
von 12 wochen aufgebraucht werden
sollten weil sie nämlich ansonsten dann
ihre vitamine mineralstoffe verlieren
und im prinzip habe ihr euch dann so
wichtigste gesagt ich werde euch video
zu scream natürlich unten in der infobox
wenn ich das video gefallen hast gern
mit euren freunden und gebt mir eine
bewertung bis zum nächsten mal